[Music]
three two one action
what the hell is my intro hi welcome to
off the record while we talk about
whatever okay it's good to be back guys
it's good to see that [ __ ] thanks
for having me again every week every
everybody loves YouTube I think I'll
need after this one I'll need a little
maybe just I'll be buggy a break
why what do we need a break from you two
I love it I love it they're just you
know I just um I need some time somehow
I'm not down with that water now how why
are you bringing the enemy into here is
that the enemy an enemy dark-eyed your
competitor what are you talking about
he's just breaking up with us and you
completely ignored I'm not breaking up I
just need me time some time so you're
talking about how it's all very long day
it's in there long day I don't know
you're an introvert I it's kind of yeah
some would say that this is my only
gateway to meeting other people outside
of these people yeah why you're gonna do
that to me we both known him long ago
what are the people you meet I leave my
share you can bring in new people I
don't want new people I want you that's
how I feel in life but no it's just you
know is the time to reset your energy
right let me set the energy especially
after this metro grade bro it's talking
what's up with this Metro great [ __ ]
y'all stupid I've never really believed
or invested into that what is it Metro
grammar much low grade
oh are you kidding yeah no yeah that was
the part of the Metro but yeah it's
[ __ ] me up like was that why I've
been stuttering and [ __ ] yeah my words
been so [ __ ] up these days more than
ever because Mercury's in retrograde
[ __ ]
yeah Marina reggaeton where's Nicki we
need a better fate keeps Ike here can
you feel it yeah yeah I got you what do
you guys wanna know what what did you
what is what is that yeah what kind of
retrograde is happening because the
planets align listen okay when Mercury's
in retrograde that means that mercury is
is behind the Sun yes yes tan so so
basically so why does that [ __ ] with us
so [ __ ] with us because mercury is the
direct communication path
four of plantera Li that allows us all
to communicate with each other better
when it's in direct view but since it's
not a direct view it is in fact behind
the Sun we are not able to communicate
effectively with one another because
Mercury's behind yep I've heard the
counter-argument where they just say
it's [ __ ] yeah and I always believe
the [ __ ] part yet because week I
used to be like right like everyone be
tweeting about the [ __ ] like Mercury
retrograde and I'd be like yo what are
y'all talking about my week has been
fine I'm good but the past couple weeks
man been bad it's been rubbing me weird
what you've been doing I don't know just
a lot of weird things have been
happening hasn't been getting hard
Mercury retrograde chill great great it
yeah that's what it is there you go
it's because the communication for the
markers behind the Sun I know your dick
can't get hard yep it means they need
the proper song yeah it's it's
misaligned I'm an Aries you know it's
just not in line because Mars is
supposed to be where I don't know where
the [ __ ] they are I'm a Virgo so in
Venus shine the Sun you know you really
into it turns into a vagina I'm very
into it so it's so you asking me if I'm
um if I'm an inch over it is interesting
right because like I just learned about
the whole rising sign and lines rising
and mooning and Moony so I'm I'm a
Pisces right and Pisces are
traditionally kind of more introverted
but then I knew a girl who had the same
birthday as me and she's like wait like
how are you able to be on wiling out and
and be in front of people if you're such
an inch over and then I looked it up
right and then I'm an Aries no no Taurus
rising so that's how people perceive you
right is that right yeah I said well
it's you're very reliable person okay
well thanks so then it's like okay that
makes it reliable thanks man
cuz my whole life people have been like
okay they think I'm like life with a
partying [ __ ] but really while I'm kind
of talking people at the party I'd much
rather just kind of be home alone you
know saying so it's like once I heard
that [ __ ] off like that name
depends what kind of party yeah it's
true dude if it's like a [ __ ] rager
with nothing but boom boom boom music
I'm out every time right depends on the
boom boom for me I need to be able to
talk to people all about boom boom how
about Schneider it's better but it's
still like yeah people well if I can't
hear if I can't hear the person I'm
talking to it's not a party to me
the like grown-up party girl forum
sometimes I prefer dancing and not
talking and I like to communicate
through moves yeah depends on their ears
yeah see I just know I'm rising
something else I forgot what my moaning
is what's your Chinese wait I just said
I was Aries earlier that's why you know
I don't know what which a Chinese zodiac
signs yeah
my Chinese zodiac is I'm a rat Oh word
but rats don't mean like a bad being
like in Western culture no one said did
the rats no I'm not saying Tim because
Tim has tiny years so it probably has a
different animal like I don't know
different no the same animal I'm Tiger
actually oh that's so sick thanks I got
my [ __ ] ox that it's the most boring
[ __ ] I'm a pig Oh your ox we're soul
mates really likes rat ox rat and
Dragons are cool okay wait what rats and
Dragons are cool rats and dragon Oh a
monkey yeah monkey
what about snake that's what I am I
don't know you're a snake no you eat
rats oh you're my cousin or the same
year 89 I guess I'll have my cousin's is
maybe now what do you work like a rat we
enjoy the song or the same year she's a
pig my mom always told me that since I
was born at like
827 in the morning that I'm a tiger when
he's sleepy so that's why I'm like
passionate but I'm lazy well how about
that
uh yeah but that makes sense you're
passionate and you're lazy wait much
that's the same that's like you can have
every characteristic and then you it'll
fit it's like you're you're you're
hateful but you're loving ya know bad
but you're happy no that's not true
that's not that's on a tiger at 8:00 in
the morning no okay a tiger in the
morning he's like he's not he's not
happy and he's anyway what were the
words happy and sad I still want to know
what are the weird [ __ ] that happened to
the last couple weeks
oh yeah what is the weird [ __ ] I thought
I was getting sued at one point yeah and
but I wasn't I wasn't I was getting
subpoenaed for another reason but like
yeah you got subpoena yeah why I was
about to I thought well I don't even
know if I'm allowed we'll be okay
without without getting into it without
getting into a tomb what happened to
your friend Tom Murphy yeah what
happened a comedy getting into too much
detail some guy was like knocking on my
door like a lot when I wasn't home and
he's like and she would be like hello
yeah what's up and he's like I have a
letter I have to give specifically to
Tim and I'm like holy [ __ ] am i eating
sued like what the [ __ ] would I even be
getting sued for is a fan yeah sounds
like a fan yeah then we thought maybe
it's a fan right so then we asked where
he was from and he named the company so
we googled inside was a law firm I'm
like holy [ __ ] I'm about to get sued and
then we called and I'm like hey are you
guys do you guys have some type of
message you need to deliver to me like
what's good is this even real you know
you really still what's good yeah no I
probably said hey um is there something
you guys need to deliver to me because I
haven't been home and they finally
called me back and they're like yeah
okay yeah it's a it's a subpoena but
you're not getting sued or your witness
kind of they have they think I might
have some video evidence for something
that someone is getting accused of oh
[ __ ] but I don't have it oh no poor
gonna have so much footage how would you
know well this is specifically from it
does it have it Joe
when you when you thought you're getting
sued and you called number you like the
Royal penis is not ready to be sued
yeah thank you it's still dirty right
now yeah I just pictured you as Timmy
character trying to do a legal situation
I got my professional voice up yeah
that's good
but yeah I thought of getting sued so
that was [ __ ] up and then like I'm in
a [ __ ] heart attack yeah it was it
was stressful and then like oh what a
hot the border is [ __ ] yeah man who I
didn't know was going on yeah and then
also like Howie and I had to do all that
while I was at playlist and I was like
yeah it's like I don't feel like talking
to people why did you go to that place
because it was already like you know
tickets were booked and all expected to
be yeah they booked it like a half a
year in advance
whoof they're like you're not going
anyway when I went with you guys last
time I was scared the whole time were
you scared of well I felt like they're
gonna do some twenty20 a [ __ ]
pedophile ring on me like that little
play out weirdest swarming with the kids
now I don't want to party with 12 year
olds although it was a great experience
though like the first ten minutes I was
like oh my [ __ ] god this is really
happening right now it's unlike anything
you've never seen before I remember last
year I think I was walking into a party
and it was a couple there was some
younger kids in front of me and I was
talking to homie I was like you gotta go
party with some 10 year olds haha
laughing in this kitchen he's like I'm
not tandem [ __ ] 12 so to become 10
years old again it's like point are you
allowed to smack him across the face I
said just mooch hey those 20 months ago
man boy I've learned a lot I'm twelve
and a half buddy
yeah I was about to asked if what was
Mercury retrograde about your weeks in
the past couple weeks but before you get
to that shoutouts to our sponsor post
mates yeah when you need red wine at 4
p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. or a breakfast
burrito at 8 a.m. or ibuprofen at 10
a.m. you can post mate it post mates is
your personal food delivery grocery
delivery whatever kind of delivery
service all year round baby anything
you're craving post mates can deliver
that the largest on-demand network in
the US and offer delivery from all the
restaurants grocery and convenience
stores and traditional retailers you
could possibly want or need 24 hours a
day
365 days a year post mates will bring
you what you need within the hour no
more trips to the store you don't even
have to know where the store is post
mates will deliver anything to you
download the app for iOS or Android for
free browse local restaurants and
businesses and track your delivery in
real time for a limited time post mate
is giving our listeners you guys $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use code off the
record that's called off the record for
$100 of free delivery credit from your
first 7 days when you download the poise
postmates twice oh wait $100 they give
you a free hug freedom I've literally
Post made it up floss before just
completed is be just floss what because
we had Post mated batteries once see
anything you need anytime you need
batteries or floss points made it down
low post maids not poison meat and save
with the code off the record back to you
- what the hell has been going on in
your life now what kind of mix thank you
bye metrosexual grade did you get Metro
wreck retro means really the day of
yesterday has the day of yesterday the
day yesterday the day of yesterday was
horrible week even as I'm saying the day
of yesterday this is was the day of
yesterday that's not your fault
more the planet I thought yours I
thought it was like some symbolic [ __ ]
you were saying the day of yesterday
every time I look up on my path I can't
well it started that way and then I said
at normal but anyway so yeah all day
yesterday was really bad
with technology specifically because so
I had I had scheduled our internet to
come in to the new house on Wednesday oh
yeah I just moved in right
congratulations
yeah and and then so on the phone that
lady told me on Wednesday you're gonna
get the internet guy to come in whatever
I put in the calendar I'm like cool
we're set for Wednesday this was on
Monday and then they said like the tout
the timeslot was from 8 to 12 and I was
reading like the 11:30 and no one showed
up so I call it on like a what the hell
how do you think I do think huh and then
they tell me oh it's actually scheduled
for the night which is a Monday and I'm
like that's not even the same day of the
week like how the [ __ ] did that happen
it's not the day before yesterday
exactly yeah yeah of the first so then I
was like what the [ __ ] so long story
short I was able to get them to come on
a Friday instead of Monday but the point
is I waited all that time no one showed
up I didn't do [ __ ] then so they're
coming tomorrow
yes tomorrow they're coming [ __ ] I
know so that we have JK news so
Wednesday nights are always filled with
JK news prep right so because of that
whole like up until 12:00 like I didn't
have any internet I was like trying to
work on the phone I was also trying to
unpack and then my grandma ended up
calling me from Mexico which I haven't
spoke to her in like a long time so then
I ended up being on the phone with her
for an hour and a half which like ate up
a hold of the day so I'm like so then
[Laughter]
but yeah so we caught up and then and
then so that happened I had to put some
[ __ ] on instagram my instagram was not
working oh it was not working and I had
to post if you don't tell the story the
way TIFF is telling it it sounds like a
normal day ya know but here's you know
what's [ __ ] up just a dad on here you
start to add on to your term natural
grade yeah I am same should happen to me
because we were waiting on someone to
come install some [ __ ] from 12:00 to
5:00 yesterday and he never came sure
were you trying to get installed a smoke
detector saw that what the [ __ ] is the
retro great thing is it like things
aren't happening the way that they're
supposed to tiger oh I'm such a [ __ ]
Titan here we go back to the air about
you okay Roy you plug a pig that's so
funny because um because when I posted
yesterday about the house so one of my
comments were like oh man party I had to
post about their backyard
yard they couldn't like just give you
that let you go salmon oh my god yes
bring the pole oh my god I want you guys
every time you even think of hosting
about your house you have to think about
what else is going I don't even I don't
even give a [ __ ] with water I just pull
the [ __ ] yeah you just flex all over
Duncan on Casey and 10th well they're
trying to [ __ ] talk about their house
talking on literally with your bathroom
oh cool oh my god [ __ ] looking sick back
there just going on before it was that
like molt was like the Tesla thing oh my
god they get a [ __ ] house to put bark
up Sophos sick guys backyard and wait
til what what comes then wow they're
gonna get a Doughboy pool above-ground
pool and then you guys are gonna finish
your very choice cuz I'm the white trash
person here I'm showing very nice
above-ground pools very affordable hey
they have those in bad boys too and they
look pretty cool
very close above the ground pool okay
Martin Lawrence and Will Smith have you
seen that one where people can like
straight up swim Michael Phelps was like
endorsed by that company hits like above
the ground boy has a current yeah it's a
girl Oh like a treadmill but pools it
was pretty funny and he was like in all
the commercials and he was like selling
the pool Wow swimming you just get push
about yeah but I feel like that could
literally be the size of leg just like a
tub right as long as you can like fit in
it it's like the currents going above
the ground lap pools for [ __ ] white
trash people who think that they're Muji
that's my favorite contender for
advanced yeah I love that [ __ ] so you
guys have a like a pool now too right
not yet it didn't get filled it okay cuz
I was like zooming in on Instagram I was
gonna pull their weight so what is the
point of retrograde though is it like a
lot of mistakes happen or things better
communication like technology [ __ ] up
on you a lot of that it's it's science
guys so you know what science is every
time I update my [ __ ] eyes products
that should get slower and [ __ ] up
yeah ice products I products like Apple
products and [ __ ] well
they just settled some lawsuit that was
like for Jamil yeah when they said oh
we're talking about that later okay
never mind so but they torqued the [ __ ]
it they found out that they actually
torqued the machines okay we could move
on and act like that never happened
anyways so point it's a lot of [ __ ]
happen yesterday you said you just
didn't even start yet so what's like the
meat of the cheese made can you tell us
well I mean just last night was the
catalyst of it all so we ended up heavy
so because we don't have internet we
have to work on JK news we ended up
going to Starbucks Casey and I nearby
the one next to the Vaughn's three to go
I like Starbucks okay yeah that's gonna
with the oneness of the buns no so
there's a lot of story they are they're
tender but no so then we ended up going
in there but then they they closed like
30 minutes later so we're like [ __ ] now
what do we do it's like 7:00 p.m. we
still have so much work to do so we
ended up coming here o to use the NA
yeah 30
that's how desperate was know you're
like going up the car doors like did it
hi where's the internet oh great that's
why I saw Casey here cuz I was here
working in a new laugh all day and you
guys came back yeah we came back could I
had dinner with me no mad to work oh we
had to work I was working too so we
didn't go to sleep till 1:30 I think I
left and you guys came right after oh
really yeah what times I would have
brought you guys dinner too at the same
time house in right here last night it
was horrible oh I'll try to work out of
here too
yeah that's the reason why we had to
work so late it was so much you guys
could just used my house well it was
late but ceiling doesn't weren't able to
communicate cm and mark mercury
retrograde to our house - it was late
I'm like dude they're not that way man
I'm kind of like in my head cuz I have
to do my my birthday we're going to
Vegas to do a live episode of our
podcast yeah we're gonna make you come
tomorrow
guests at the Palms night you guys are
setting up mics inside of your room no
no no it's it's a whole [ __ ] um event
and we're doing like a little segment of
it so like but in my head I'm like oh
this shit's supposed to the retrograde
supposed to last until the 10th right so
a part of me is like the shadow week Tim
what does that mean Nicki how do you
guys not understand after it's over
there's a whole week of it still kind of
linger angers gonna stay in my head I
feel like ah I hope this does him [ __ ]
me up while I'm in Vegas and then also
in my head I'm like what am i letting
this preconceived [ __ ] [ __ ] like
throw off my vibe before you've been
going in so I thought you're a Christian
too you don't believe in Jesus I believe
in the universe and the balance of the
universe and that God is a part of that
but if Jesus is on your side none of
this [ __ ] hocus-pocus [ __ ] matters
yeah but Jesus can't communicate to you
because heaven is behind the Sun right
now exactly these has no reception
what are supposed to believe the [ __ ]
Aries [ __ ] or the tiger shirt or the
Christian shooting the moon [ __ ] I guess
it's relative to your culture I know I
just believe in Ray Bradbury
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]